[Musique]
le président du département a reçu ce
mercredi 11 septembre les principaux et
gestionnaires des collèges dans les
jardins de la villa du département à
l'occasion de ce rendez vous annuel la
collectivité a souhaité remettre à 12
jeunes la médaille départementale pour
les concours auxquels ils ont participé
il est important d'être à l'écouté de
notre jeunesse notamment de ces jeunes
dans nos collèges qui au quotidien
viennent bien sûr pour se former
recevoir une éducation des
qualifications mais aussi pour se former
à la citoyenneté par mieux le concours
de sciences c'est génial mais aussi le
plumier d'or en concours de langue
française ou encore le concours de radio
des collégiens saut à nariman élève au
collège joseph bed-in également reçu une
médaille pour sa participation au
concours the voice tiff 7 foncier débat
c'est que ben et de voix la réunion se
tient moins comme ça de voir que ma
famille dia - ma famille on chemine
heureux de la réunion les quotas de
moins et bassamois beaucoup plaisir et
me réalise pas encore et raïs pour cause
pâte et arrive là mais ferment est très
grand plaisir
un prix a également été décernée au
collège de la marine à vincendo qui
remporte le concours ne gaspille ici par
le département qui consiste à diminuer
le gaspillage alimentaires dans les
cantines d'un travail
du réfectoire pendant les repas pour
peser les éléments les aliments qu'ils
étaient gaspillés et ensuite au novateur
dans la mis en place plusieurs concours
concours se forme d'acrostiches avec le
mot gaspillage et donc à partir de grâce
à ce travail donc on a ensuite fait un
jury et on a ensuite fait imprimer par
une entreprise une grande des grandes
pales gris talent le résultat du travail
qui se trouve maintenant dans le
réfectoire et qu'on veut a proposé
d'ailleurs aux autres établissements de
la réunion le département est le
partenaire essentiel de la réussite
éducative et de l'épanouissement des
collégiens trois opérations sur leur
lancée cette année le concours ni au
gaspi celui de l'embellissement des
collèges mais aussi le concours du film
scolaire c'est aussi l'occasion
l'ensemble de ces concours pour les
enfants et les équipes de pouvoir
découvrir des projets je pense à
certains enfants qui nous ont dit mais
moi ce que j'ai envie de faire ces
jardiniers en fête ou d'autres qui se
sont dit mais le cadrage c'est
extraordinaire donc on suscite des
vocations comme ça à travers ces
concours qui met en place une synergie
dans chaque établissement c'est venu une
synergie projet une matinée qui a permis
de dresser un bilan des actions menées
par la collectivité en faveur de la
réussite éducative
le président a annoncé la construction
de 2000 au collège immigrés en 2021 dans
le quartier de roquefeuil à saint-paul
et en 2020 lieu à la plaine des
palmistes
[Musique]